our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
the death of george floyd earlier this
year set off weeks of protests and
unrest in cities all across the country
and chicago was no no exception adriana
diaz shows us how one group of teenagers
there turned their anger
into action and transformed a looted
liquor store
into something their community needed
this summer's unrest in chicago
following the killing of george floyd
left many young people feeling lost i
really felt like cornered and confused
as to why i couldn't be a part of the
change i wanted to see
to help fifteen-year-old friends azaria
baker and keith tinkson
turned to their after school program by
the hand club for kids
which organized listening circles with
mentors like former chicago bears player
sam ocho
the conversation revolved a lot around
despair it was almost like
they were being devalued with not only
with seeing
black people getting killed but also
seeing just the rioting and their
looting that ensued
out of the destruction they saw an
opportunity
build a fresh food market where a looted
liquor store used to stand
my neighborhood is a food desert it's
also 12 liquor stores
and a one mile radius you have to go
a mile and a half just to see a fresh
food market
you would think that a grocery store or
community would be like a basic
necessity but that's not for us
but the project would cost half a
million dollars
so ocho enlisted 14 other athletes to
help
you guys donate anywhere from uh one
thousand to
a hundred thousand dollars yes yes
yes yes this is a great fella
oh my god
no he's just excited danita travis
who runs by the hand club had been
trying to close that liquor store for 10
years how did you feel when you saw it
all come down
i'm telling you it's one of the best
days of my life the kids they've been
through
so much over the last five months they
wanted to show
everyone that there's positive things
happening in this community
provide economic status to our youth
they studied pricing and marketing
to be ready for opening day
really yes it's not the limit star's not
the limit
for 12 weeks the students will work the
market after school
and it pays well how does that feel
going to make me act up on cameraman
and how important is it to have economic
opportunities and jobs
in areas where there aren't enough it's
incredibly powerful like people who had
economic status stepped in and they
helped us to get this achieved
now we're giving people in our community
economic status and without we can do
anything
and the community is thankful can you
believe that where we're standing used
to be a liquor store
oh i guess i cannot believe that it's
going to turn into
something finally something beautiful
and nice yeah
a neighborhood in need nourishing itself
for cbs this morning adriana diaz
chicago what a great feeling to be a
teenager and think sky is not the limit
star is not the limit
people go their whole lives and don't
get that feeling so bravo
and then to have a job after school
that's not really good for your
neighborhood but it's putting money in
your pocket
every way around every way around it's
so impressive what they've done
and i'm looking at sam acho going well
number one ocho name is familiar to us
because of emanuel
acho with that knockout podcast
uncomfortable conversations with a black
man
they kind of look alike sound alike why
because they're brothers
that kind of goodness runs in the family
very well and it's amazing what all
those athletes did to kick in
yes very well done